y es que uno podría pensar que un
campeonato como la copa américa femenina
el más importante de suramérica que da
tres cupos directos al mundial de nueva
zelanda y australia y que además otorga
dos cupos a juegos olímpicos pues
tendría todo el sistema tecnológico y
propio de la vídeo asistencia para los
árbitros y en este caso en la copa
américa no lo tiene y el nivel del
arbitraje tampoco ha sido bueno han
habido reclamos han habido unas
decisiones que incluso por parte de la
prensa han sido contradictorias e
increíbles de que sucedan en un nivel de
ese nivel futbolístico de esta copa
américa así es se está definiendo
demasiado para no tener un vídeo
arbitraje de asistencia para para todo
el tema del juzgamiento
las jugadoras se han quejado han hablado
han dicho que no que no puede ser y
además la conmebol tampoco ha dejado muy
claro cuál es la posición o qué va a
pasar para la copa américa incluso en un
comunicado frente a este tema dijeron
que quizás tal vez podría aparecer en
algún momento del campeonato como un
tema fantasmagórico hablamos con ellas y
eso nos dijeron frente a este tema me
extraña mucho no entiendo el por qué no
hay bar si en todas las competencias se
utiliza el bar y en esta no al menos en
esta fase me es preocupante porque
claramente el nivel de las árbitras a
veces no está a la altura
y claro yo a ella se tienen que preparar
al igual que nosotras
espero que lo que resta en la próxima
competencia exista al bar porque es
necesario pero hablemos de lo que nos
interesa si mañana no tienen planes y el
domingo estaba un poco libre siéntense
en sus casas o si están en la ciudad de
cali vayan al estadio porque la cuarta
fecha del grupo a va a definir muchas
cosas a primera hora chile enfrentar a
bolivia un chile que quiere ganar que
quiere sumar seis puntos si quiere de
verdad estar disputando en la última
fecha ese cupo directo al mundial y a la
semifinal en bolivia que no se va a
dejar por supuesto que le ha costado en
muchísimo a los rivales vencerlo y que
por supuesto va a ser un partido
definitivo a segunda hora el plato
fuerte colombia la anfitriona va a
querer clasificarse de antemano porque
lo puede hacer a la fase final frente a
un ecuador que no se va a dejar que
quiere disfrutar también así que
tendremos un plato futbolero muy
importante muy bueno de ver y además
vamos a tener mucho público en las
graderías aquí en la ciudad de cali